is there some extra challenge to the
fact that Alice is such a big robot
there is the humanoid form is um
attractive in many ways but it's also a
challenge in many ways
um you have this big upper body that has
a lot of mass and inertia
um and throwing that inertia around
increases the complexity of maintaining
balance and as soon as you pick up
something heavy in your arms you've made
that problem even harder
and so uh in the early work in the leg
lab and in the early days at the company
and we were pursuing these quadruped
robots which had a
a kind of built-in simplification you
have this big rigid body and then really
light legs so when you swing the legs
the leg motion didn't impact the body
motion very much
all the mass and inertia was in the body
but when you have the humanoid that
doesn't work you have big heavy legs you
swing the legs it affects everything
else
and so
dealing with all of that interaction
does make the humanoid a much more
complicated platform
and I also saw that uh at least recently
you've been doing more explicit modeling
of the stuff you pick up yeah which is
very
um really interesting so you have to
what model the shape
the weight distribution
[Music]
I don't know what like you have to under
like include that as part of the
modeling as part of the planning because
okay so for people who don't know
uh so Atlas at least in like a recent
video like throws a heavy bag throws a
bunch of you know stuff so what what's
involved in uh picking up a thing a
heavy thing
uh and when that thing is a bunch of
different non-standard things I think it
also picked up like a barbell
and to be able to throw in some cases
what are some interesting challenges
there
so we were definitely trying to show
that the robot and the techniques we're
applying to the Rope to Atlas let us
deal with heavy things in the world
because if the robot's gonna be useful
it's actually got to move stuff around
yeah and that and that needs to be
significant stuff that's an appreciable
portion of the the body weight of the
robot
and we also think this differentiates us
from the other humanoid robot activities
that you're seeing out there mostly
they're not picking stuff up yet
and not heavy stuff anyway
um but just like you or me you know you
need to anticipate that moment you know
you're reaching out to pick something up
and as soon as you pick it up your
center of mass is going to shift
and if you're gonna you know turn in a
circle you have to take that inertia
into count and if you're going to throw
a thing you know you've got all of that
has to be sort of included in in the
model of what you're trying to do
so the robot needs to have some idea or
expectation of what that weight is and
then and sort of predict you know think
a couple of seconds ahead how do I
manage my now my my body plus this big
heavy thing together to get and and
still maintain balance right and so um I
I uh that's a big change for us and I
think the tools we've built are really
allowing that to happen quickly now some
of those motions that you saw in that
most recent video we were able to create
in a matter of days it used to be it
took six months to do anything new you
know on the robot and and now we're
starting to develop the tools that let
us do that in a matter of days and so we
think that's really exciting it means
that the ability to create new behaviors
for the robot is going to be a
a quicker process so being able to
explicitly model
new things that it might need to pick up
new types of things and you know to some
degree you don't you don't want to have
to pay too much attention to each
specific thing right
um there's sort of a generalization here
yeah
um obviously when you grab a thing you
have to conform your your hand your end
effector to the surface of that shape
but once it's in your hands it's
probably just the mass and inertia that
matter and the the shape may not be as
important yeah and so you know for some
in some ways you want to pay attention
to that detailed shape and in others you
want to generalize it and say uh well
all I really care about is the center of
mass of this thing especially if I'm
going to throw it up on that scaffolding
and it's easier if the body is rigid
what if it's there's some doesn't it
throw like a sandbag type thing that
tool bag you know you've had loose had
loose stuff in it yeah so it it managed
that there are harder things that we
haven't done yet you know we could have
had a big jointed thing or I don't know
a bunch of loose wire or rope what about
carrying another robot how about that
yeah we haven't we haven't done that yet
I guess we did a little bit of a we did
a a little skit around Christmas where
we had two spots holding up another spot
that was trying to put you know a bow on
a tree so I guess we're doing that in a
small way
okay that's pretty good